I love this man's work he is all over it
and he hid being the NBA and anybody
associated with the Association and his
reporting on what happened over the
weekend caused me to lift the phone and
say hey tell me what's what tell me what
happened and that is Chris Haines of
Yahoo Sports how are you Chris are you
there Chris Haines I'm here now oh good
and how are you sir you well everybody
in your family good yeah you know I
think you know we've been in the house
about three months I'm getting used to
my family again there are some good
times there's some bad time I think if I
am going to Orlando to cover that that
restart yes I think a large portion of
my family in the house is be happy to
see me go okay well and again that's an
interesting part about all this we even
just had Jay Bilas on last hour talking
about hey if you go cover some go cover
the NBA and you've got to go leave for
3-4 months you got to make a decision
yourself and you know and that also puts
into perspective that the athletes
involved in all of these sports and the
conversations that are we had there are
human beings they're human beings first
and and and and that's where I want to I
guess lead this conversation to your
report over the weekend what did Kyrie
Irving organize over the weekend what
did happen over the weekend in this this
video conference with NBA stars here it
was a call about 80 players at one point
it got to I want to say facts of 84
players in yeah and it was stars from
all all ranges stars I mean it was
players from all ranges so it wasn't
just stars Kevin Durant Russell
Westbrook right there but yeah basically
he wanted to give everybody who felt
like they didn't have a voice in this
process want to give him a platform to
hear their grievances hear their
concerns but it was a platform where a
lot of young guys got to talk Donovan
Mitchell you know BAM in Orlando David
Mitchell made a point
that you know he felt like with his
extension being you know being coming up
this summer you know he was hesitant to
play because he didn't want to mess up
his chance to you know get a max
contract he felt like if he came back
what if he got hurt you know that a mess
things up on his hand and so there's a
bunch of concerns and you know Dwight
Howard Carmelo Anthony me Avery Bradley
they all kind of agree with Kyrie that
you know there's more important things
one all-in plan and then but most of but
that was just that was the minority you
know was about five or six guys who let
it be known that they weren't interested
in plan they felt like this is a time to
make change what's going on in our
society right now and the other portion
you know the other people that it was
just trying to explain to them the
ramifications of not playing so that
there wasn't there wasn't enough
opposition to say this thing is headed
in a place where there's not going to be
a season that's not the case at all it
was just I think I really just given
people a platform just feel like you
know feel like they're in this process
and that because that's what a lot of
young folks young young players that was
their criticism that they didn't have a
boat in the SE of the seasons gonna we
saw tonight okay so would you please
give more of an airing to the philosophy
that you said was in the minority that
that instead of protest being part of
the sport protest instead of the sport
and and who was that Kyrie and Dwight
Howard I mean who and give it a little
bit more of an airing on that theory in
philosophy if you don't mind Chris that
was yeah that was on Kyrie Dwight Howard
Avery Bradley Carmelo Anthony I think
who else I know I'm missing somebody but
you know they're still you know
Donovan's Jonathan's his concern was you
know his his extension it was more song
that obviously with with the company he
was you know he was not you know he
would teach at deposit for corona before
so you know that's the on his mind as
well but here
his main concern in that call you know
sources say was no extension that you
can receive the sunburn not jeopardizing
getting a max contract but most of the
guys that had a problem was going and
being planned it was due to you know the
racial injustice going on in aftermath
the George flood tragedy and so they
were white Howard you know he was
passionate
he felt like if they don't take a stand
now like what are we going to stand for
it he felt like you know players were
saying you know just the optics of just
being huddled out there in Orlando just
being stuck you know just bad optics for
a league that's majority
african-american just to be stuck over
there just for entertaining purposes and
economical factors and so they felt like
you know we gotta make a make a stand
right now and take a stand at you know
this is not about money you know there
wouldn't be some sacrifices yes but we
feel like you know we have to be on the
front lines
that's what Kyrie Irving was saying by
he was willing to risk it all to be on
the front lines and try to to make a
make a difference in the community so
though those were those were some of
those were some of the reasons though
some things that they were voiced you
know during this call and and you know
it was a call in a car going through you
know this wasn't a Paul sanctioned by
the Players Association no Kyrie is vice
president a player association so this
kind of this came out of nowhere you
know and Chris Paul would be got people
you know he was a part of it I mean he
he called in but this is what this
wasn't something that he sanctioned and
so uh you know was a little bit of a
monkey wrench sort of say but you know
at the end of the day I you know it I
felt like it was it was one that was
unified it had a lot of people talking
out for but B know who's wanted quiet
guys be you know he was very talkative
in the community and so it at the end of
the day it was a good phone call to get
everybody on the same page just to see
where to go hear from now and if
anything just the Gillette allow people
to have a voice who who normally
wouldn't Chris Haynes of Yahoo Sports
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
where does it go
here British I don't think this changes
anything no look that the simple the
simple fact that matter is if you don't
want to play if you don't want to go you
won't get paid for those games that's it
nobody's forcing the please nobody's
forcing the players to go over there and
so then like I said there there's not
enough opposition out there like if you
poll it you know have four hundred fifty
of the players you know the players I
said it they're not going or don't want
to go this they're going to be the
minority most players want to go over
there and play and largely largely and
because of financial ramifications you
know they're the owners I mean the
players feel like if they didn't play
owners SCBA up which yeah which would
most likely happen and that 50/50 Bri
split the thing I have now it wouldn't
be anywhere close to that so there
there's the financial ramifications on a
major major factor and why both players
want to go over there and play but it
doesn't change anything this season will
be restarted it will resolve in a letter
it will okay
it seems that Patrick Beverley made an
insinuation that they're playing only
because LeBron says yes would you agree
did you hear that one Chris please I
wouldn't say I wouldn't say he he's
saying like it if a bronze plan we're
gonna play that's it I think he I think
he respects LeBron as a basketball mind
and know that if he believes you know he
believed LeBron has the best interests
of the league and I think that's why I
pat pat Wynton said that look you know
LeBron you know LeBron has a lot to lose
you know he's not getting any younger
the Lakers one of the hottest teams in
the league before this thing is you know
LeBron is big on legacy you know yes he
wants to finish the season out and try
to get a championship it would mean so
much to the Lakers but it would mean so
much to his legacy to bring a title to
Elector so you know definitely for
personal reasons
LeBron will want to play but you know
LeBron he's a businessman and he
understands how a player making 10
million a year right now that player
should be making five
million next year if that CPA just tore
up so you know they they and for years
and down the road had this ripple effect
years later so he understands the
business side I'm not going out there in
place so they dock to read the voice and
all along even with the superstar call
that I reported about two or three weeks
ago with about 7/8 of superstars on the
call you know they made it clear like it
was in the best interest to play if the
lis can assure them that they'll have
some of the safe most safest safest
measures you know around possible so I
guess let's just bring this conversation
full circle in a way with you Chris
Haynes a Yahoo Sports you know where you
mention how kovat nineteen has placed a
little bit of stress in your household
as it has and everybody that's been
quarantined a family begins to feel a
little bit of more of a pressure point
based on what's going on with this virus
how many how many folks are in your
household Chris include my wife and
[Laughter]
imagine I'm imagining all ages correct
of all ages okay so this is perfect in
terms of bring this old so everyone's
got a different agenda okay and
everybody's got a different agenda and
so in the fact that I'm hearing what you
had to say about the NBA here everyone's
got different agendas or different
concerns let's put it this way let's put
a different concerns and and wants and
desires that covet nineteen is beginning
to place pressure points on isn't it
possible or is this too optimistic that
the NBA can all get together and that
for those who are saying we shouldn't be
playing we should be protesting that the
NBA is used as the platform from which
the protests and the conversations can
be used as a platform can be used to to
get out and and and bring the attention
into the arena that
and then be sent out into the community
and the owners and the players can you
know continue the business and at the
end somebody hoist the trophy and they
say there's no asterisk here you try and
come to a spot for three months and
figure this thing out and and play in a
pandemic right don't you think that
that's possible Chris no that's very
possible no it's very possibly and
that's what that's what the players on
the other side of the fence that was
what they were saying and one of those
players is Garrett temple who was also a
member of the Executive Committee for
the players he was saying like there
will be a bigger platform for us to make
a bigger change if we went out there and
played you know all eyeballs are being
on the NBA everybody wants to see this
sport man and of course the league would
understand you know the flight of the
the African American and what's going on
right now how everybody has been
affected by this
mostly physically it's been a training
process so of course the league will do
what they can within their parameters to
make sure the voice the players voice is
heard and that they're able to do
something in honor or do something in a
way to give back and give them a
platform to do so and so that's like I
said rich you know that's why you asked
the question I think the league's would
be a spot yes this is not going to stop
anything you know that that that call
but like I read was more so just for
people to have a voice because when the
vote was approve about two weeks ago
that proved when the players approved
the NBA's 22 team format yes a lot of
players like hold on I didn't have a
face like what's going on like I didn't
vote like I didn't do so that that
that's what that call was about okay so
when we hear about unity coming out of
the call it's as if okay we've all been
heard and more feel more unified going
forward here not unified in not playing
is what you're saying
everybody's been even I read earlier in
the call you know he was like I don't
want to go like I'm not I don't plan on
going you know I want to do what I have
to do in my community work on the front
line I paid a lot of money you know I'm
more on the wrist at all but later in
the call the call lasted for about a
hour
minutes later on in that call Chiron
said you know what guys I'm glad that
I'm glad that we had this talk I feel
good about where we're headed now if
everybody feels like it's in our best
interest to go over there in Orlando
then I'm gonna be with you guys and so
that's why that's why I said that's why
I wrote it and I like that it was a
unifying call everybody not getting on
the same page but just hearing everybody
out because that was the main thing
people felt like they didn't have a
voice okay so to use I guess an analogy
he came in thinking figuratively the the
world was flat and now he sees it as
round is what you're saying Chris just
trying to bring some levity to this
world man Chris your reporting is so
great and I appreciate you coming on to
share it and I look forward to doing it
again you got it right back at you at
Chris B Haines follow him on Twitter I
do you should too he's plugged in to say
the least
plugged in and hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here